what's up genius mindset hey what's up
let me help
what do you got I've been a leader in my
school for calcula group of students I'm
not able to lead them properly they have
problem with me I am not able to
understand what to do what's the problem
I have very bad communication skills
like I can't talk to someone making a
good eye contact you're talking to me
you've made eye contact the whole time
like I'm very afraid
talking to the seniors and the juniors
too I don't know why when it comes to
look I can't talk first of all it's
awesome and listen like the the
vulnerability and the willingness to
share that is great and like just
recognize them as amazing there's
nothing inherently wrong with you like
you can do it you're talking to me you
have understood everything you said it's
fantastic
I think the way through is two things
one to lead other people you have to
lead yourself first so to lead yourself
that's coming from your own confidence
it's your own sense of I'm I have value
to bring like I I care about the work
that I'm doing I'm doing meaningful
things right like if you have self
confidence in yourself people will be
attracted to that if people are sensing
a lack of confidence a lack of Direction
a lack of understanding is really hard
to lead people like people don't want to
follow that they want to follow
something that they're they want to see
in themselves how do you get there it's
leaning in on the things that you are
afraid of so you get it by practicing
you want to learn how to skateboard
you're gonna get on a skateboard and
fall over a thousand times and then
you're gonna get up and you're gonna be
able to skate down the hill and then
you're gonna learn how to do the tricks
the two things I'd recommend for you is
any time that you feel yourself afraid
of something then you have to go and do
that thing and it's not about don't
don't tie your confidence or your
self-worth to getting the result tie it
to the attempt tie it to trying like
there's a senior who you want to talk to
and get their opinion on something you
might go and talk to them and they laugh
at you or you stumble there
say your idea is the stupidest idea I've
ever heard in my life get out of my face
right like that could happen I'm not
gonna say like you're gonna go up and be
amazing right like that will happen
that can't happen you can suck at the
beginning yeah the win for you is that
you did the thing you went off and did
it even though you were afraid like even
here lots of people want to want to join
in and ask questions the first person is
always the it always takes time for the
first person to say yes and then after
this is gonna be like lots of you pick
me next pick me that right so you
already have it in you like I don't know
if you were afraid to come on and do
this or not some you know some guy on
Instagram some questions but you have it
in you to take the step and so it's it's
taking this step more anytime you feel
yourself afraid to do the thing do the
thing even if you don't care about that
thing like when I when I got my nails
painted I didn't want I didn't need to
get my nails paint I didn't want to get
my nails painted it's because I was
afraid to get my nails painted that I
had to go and get my nails painted so if
you're afraid to do something especially
from somebody else's opinion then you
have to go and do that thing practice
that anytime you feel yourself playing
small not being a leader every time you
feel that and then you play small you
lose respect for yourself every time you
feel that and you do the scary thing you
build respect for yourself and I want
you to tie the sense of worthiness to
the fact that you took the action not to
the result that you got from it because
if you continue to take the action you
will get better at it and then you will
get results and people will listen to
you and people will follow you
so don't expect to William the first
time out don't expect your first
conversation to be amazing although you
might I think you're out you really hard
on yourself because listen I've had lots
of people on this show and it's hard to
understand what they're saying I don't
understand their question you know like
you communicate well you've maintained
eye contact the whole time like it's
easy to understand what you're saying so
I and it's fine I mean people are hard
on the cells you're hard on yourself I'm
super hard on myself it's fine just
don't let that that hardest on yourself
be so hard then you don't take action
like it's kicking yourself down instead
of using as a kick forward to get better
it looks like it's night time for you
but can you have a conversation with
somebody today or tomorrow that you like
who are you afraid to have a
conversation yeah I had conversation
with my teachers today and some of my
juniors so I was fumbling and I was not
able to talk to them what I have to say
I was totally messed up that happened
today yeah any more than what like
either sooner this this is this is we
can get to this place I think this is
the best like this is the best like that
you went in talk to your junior team
features and and just fell all over your
face and we're terrible that's the best
because you can go back and do it again
and get better so many people have no
idea how they want to grow they have no
idea what to learn next like you have
clarity you might suck at the thing you
want to do but you know you want to get
better at it it's amazing like the
challenge is awesome can you go back to
one of them tomorrow and have the
conversation again yeah I would 11-bit
are you scared to do it no not now not
only something else in like who is
somebody who you'd be afraid to talk to
you tomorrow
principal go talk to your friends yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah just go and and if
you fail it's amazing if you go up and
you say and then you walk out that's
amazing just the fact that you did the
thing that you are afraid to do is
amazing tomorrow what time you're going
to talk to you principal afternoon okay
after you do that message you mean DM me
okay DM me like a video or a text just
to see that you did it I don't care I
don't care if you got a result or not
like that you knocked in the door and
you shook the principal's hand and you
said here's what do you here's what I
think like what do you want to talk to
your principal about I want to talk
about my subject how can I improve in
that okay so what are you gonna go up
and say what's with hello mr. principal
mr. principal I want to take your advice
for this object how can you improve in
particular topic like that oh you're
asking for it that's that's such it yes
and that's such an easy way
who's gonna say no to that hi I'm a
student I'm looking for advice can you
please help me it's you're not asking so
you're not going to say yo this school
sucks like you need to get more teachers
right okay dude you have to do it
tomorrow you have to do it after you're
gonna DM me with the with a video or or
attacks anything DM me and and and if
you don't I'm never gonna talk to you
again no I will do
I'm never gonna okay bring you back in
here and I'm gonna be pissed
no no I'll do okay good I'm DME DME okay
so that's first like anytime you feel
anytime you feel scared worried about
judgment like how long you've been
putting off to talk with the principal
three ponies okay that's not that bad
that's not that bad listen 340 is not
that bad some people wait three four
years before they do the thing right
whether it's did it happen with me yeah
but but listen it will always happen
until you learn to fix it and do the
thing this will happen for the rest of
your life like you will not go get the
job you want you will not ask the girl
out that you want you will not become
the entrepreneur that you want like you
will constantly find reasons not to do
the thing that you want to do because
you're afraid of somebody else's opinion
it's like this is this is how you crush
it learning like the principle becomes
everything the principle becomes every
big problem or fear that you have and if
you learn to crush it and you go have
the conversation then you build that
identity that then the next time you're
scared of something you're gonna do it
that you follow through that you take
action right so it's good it's only been
three four days but a lot of people wait
three four years and a lot people wait
like forever and they never do it and
then they're 85 and they hate their life
like I never did the thing that I want
to do like you're super you learn this
like how will do you right now you're on
the 15 oh my god dude you learn this at
15 like you're set for life man you're
set for life dude you will be
unstoppable you learn this at 15 you are
set for life and then the second thing
is just try to have something in your
environment that builds up your your
confidence your esteem like who's your
favorite if you watch my videos like
who's a person you love the most from
the people that we both like I I watched
on with you you
and garyvee like I listen to to three of
you so okay like I follow your channel
constantly perf it's so like listen you
picked the three like most the people
who produce the most content may tom
bill you and gary vaynerchuk produce the
most content in the entrepreneurs based
period so so you never there's always
something to watch right that there's
never an excuse like if you loved one
person but they're only posting once a
month then you have to find extra
sources but like we we produce too much
content for you to consume all of us
every day right so so what do I try to
do is like if watching one of my videos
or Tom or Gary gives you more confidence
a boost anything then like start your
day with that so like tomorrow morning
plan out your time before you go to
school or before you talk to your
principal put on a video from whoever
whoever you feel most connected to like
I don't care if it's me or somebody else
but to get that so you start just like
me and Tom and Gary we're in your ear
like we're your mentors we're on your
shoulder saying hey dude do this come on
let's go because you may not be getting
that from your friends your parents or
the people around you now but that's
okay like you get the pick who your
mentors are and so I like every day
every day maybe don't take a day off
every day me or Gary or Tom or or some
new person you discover who you like
even better and then you say Evan sucks
awesome like consumed that person no
that's okay it's uh give me right
consume that person every day so you
start building you build the habit you
build the mindset and then back to the
first point whenever you get faced with
that fear of judgment you have to go do
that thing what time you get a message
to you tomorrow afternoon mmm
I don't got the five because I have to
go coaching management dance and workout
in all five o'clock I'm writing a book I
love it five o'clock your time five
o'clock your time so he said like 5 p.m.
yeah quite being well what time is it
there right now I don't mean 10:00 at
night ok it's like 1 o'clock for me ok
ok so like my morning okay good perfect
you're gonna do it well I'm not gonna
talk to you again and and you're gonna
ruin my entire Saturday like my entire
weekend is ruined now if you don't do
this
I'm gonna be thinking about it Nina's
gonna be upset like my entire weekend is
gonna be I may not even post at all
Instagram that's it everybody watching
is now like screwed over
there's no stories you can go yeah okay
good okay good
I'm like I'm trying to put as much
pressure to make this happen because
when you when you do it it's gonna feel
great and then you'll be willing and
able to do the next thing and the next
thing and then talk to that cute girl
and then you know talk to that
entrepreneur whatever conversation you
want to have next and I probably should
like this is one of the most this is the
thing that messes up adults like one of
the things I see the most in adults 30
40 50 60 is like they still have these
fears over doing something they want to
do having that conversation approaching
that person if you figure that out at 15
dude like you are you will be
unstoppable it is one of the most
important life skills that you will ever
learn and it all starts with tomorrow's
conversation with the principal I'm
gonna do it all right man I'm cheering
for you good luck I'm gonna wake up and
look at my phone and wait for your
message thank you so much all right take
care man good luck
if you want to know what myself and
other successful entrepreneurs think
about how to build confidence check out
my 250 for confidence series where every
morning for the next 250 for mornings I
will send you a video that is 30 seconds
to 5 minutes long absolutely for free
that as you watch them it'll help you
build unstoppable confidence check out
the link in the description below
surround yourself with greatness
realizing that any big endeavor is the
collection of a lot of small steps if
you're doing work that you love you're
more likely to follow through raise your
standard Apple at the core its core
value is that that people passion not
one drop of my self-worth depends on
your acceptance a man if you want to
continue to learn how to build your
self-respect check out the AMA video I
did the link is right there next to me I
think you're gonna enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there I'm
pumped to be here we're doing an AMA
answering your questions so